okay we had a conversation with someone
um
who's been listening to the podcast a
long time
and
really great dude and he's like listen
man uh we can tell them who it is
can we yeah
okay yeah yeah it's not like it's it's
our youtube partner manager yeah so this
guy is like our direct contact at
youtube yeah just started working with
him great guy we have to be careful
because now they know it's someone with
some power yeah they'll be like yo next
time talk about diarrhea take their
[ __ ] channel down
so he said you know i used to watch you
guys on saturday mornings i'd like kind
of wake up i go
you know walk out grab grab my brunch
i'd come back sit down throw you guys on
and then i had to stop this these are
his words very professional dude but he
goes i'd have to stop [ __ ] doing that
because you guys kept
talking about diarrhea we we hear you
and oh i got another one
a diarrhea story i i got another like
message from someone that they were like
it was like
this long and it was like a visceral
just like hatred to to the stuff that we
were talking about and she was like we
ruined
not only her saturday but like weeks of
her life okay
and she was like you have to stop okay
complete you plea you have to stop well
we're here to officially say
saturday brunch is back on it's back on
we're committing to you know if you
listen to this podcast for a while you
know it's a cyclical thing mm-hmm we had
the [ __ ] terrorism phase we had we had
this we had to knock it out it comes and
goes for sure and so now we're on the
down cycle
of
of
diarrhea talk cleaning it up we're
buttoning it up
no more talk
microwaving
anything let's just say that yeah
what we're not the only thing we'll be
heating up
is not a packet of
salt a pack of sauce yeah sauce yeah
yeah
wouldn't even do that because we want to
splatter the sauce or anything like that
you know
we wouldn't want it to explode in any
way
so listen saturdays are back okay we're
gonna we're gonna calm it down you can
resume eating to this podcast is
basically what we're saying
but you know if you want a podcast on
hard mode we are doing a perverse family
dedicated podcast
and if you want to do some extreme
podcast listening
you know
don't even
joke about what would be on that show
wait [ __ ] no no wait no saturdays are
back
you gotta knock it off i was talking to
somebody who
who watches the podcast
yesterday and uh he was talking about
like the i don't know all the stuff and
i was like did you
watch the perverse family he's like no i
never looked it up i was like good good
good
he's like but now that you can see it
right now yeah
i did get a really funny message from
someone that said why did you make me
watch that i'm like i didn't make you do
anything yeah we said don't take
responsibility but i actually was like
good i'm glad that you didn't that's a
good thing that's what we wanted people
to do yeah and then he was like yeah but
i found the funniest picture on twitter
oh is it the lady with the bedpan yeah
yeah
how did you know that oh that that one
was doing the rounds how did you that's
crazy i didn't even say anything about
the pic and you knew
that was [ __ ] wild that
oh man that is a i can't explain it
though that is killing me that is a
christmas log if i've seen one i guess
that's it that's it i'm gonna say is it
was a nurse
holding a bedpan
which featured what looked like
something on the antique roadshow you
did not know if that came out of a human
or if that was dug up somewhere it was
crazy yeah i felt like i could have
grabbed that thing with two hands and
unlocked
like a combination with it and a genie
would have came out that's it was so
insane
it was insane
and then there was like a reply
did you like read oh i didn't see the
little dollar right there there was
another one this
dude that like had opened a stall door
in some public bathroom
and just like zoomed in on what was in
the toilet and it just looked like a
bundle of firewood
straight up like the biggest
and it's just like
it's so funny because it's not really
that gross it's just like mind-bending
how was that even physically
what were the logistics of that
it's the christmas season man i guess
but like
so many things have to happen for that
to happen you know what i'm saying yeah
did seven people come together and just
each throw a stick in yeah maybe yeah
that's what it was
people are like you said saturdays are
back they're back they're back-to-back
they're back they're back sorry they're
back
they're back
not even 10 seconds when we broke the
right saturdays are back saturdays
they're back
as of now as of now
oh man
um you see the uh fake trump christmas
card no neither
i'm on his email list so he doesn't
really talk about these things oh nice
nice nice yeah as an investor in his
spac i get the investor updates via
email so
this is pretty funny i'm actually part
of a dow to get him to own twitter
dude why does his shirt look like a like
a penis man that's the point
and the smoke all right is that smoke
i'm an idiot oh santa
is like tuxedo looks like a dick yeah
and his head is the head of the dick and
then there's like a like santa and some
reindeers in the sky and it looks like
jizz
yeah and that's they're all aimed at a
star which should probably be someone's
[ __ ]
right
yeah yes i guess yeah that's a good
thing i apologize saturdays are back
though
oh come is fine
yeah but you just said into somebody's
[ __ ] oh yeah you're right yeah that
like nra family christmas card oh my god
they're
so ridiculous that had me laughing
that had me
i was laughing so hard at this yeah this
is it right here who is this guy this is
the purge 5 cover yeah
it is so funny to grab the family to
make like the expendables poster
you know what i mean that's like stay
them rock
[ __ ] stallone a great tweet that was
like when you when you already look like
a dweeb guns
make you look so much to
and it's like that's the perfect way of
phrasing that because i can't quite put
my finger on like what is
such a so like horribly cringy about
this picture yeah
it's because like when you dress like
it's i don't know if you guys are
already like a dweeby family
like these giant odd fully automatic
weapons in your hand like you don't look
cooler
because it looks so regular i just feel
like
as soon as they took this picture like
this chaos ensued like the guy's like
great shot
[Laughter]
and dead
like he shoots his wife and then the guy
gets scared and unloads and a bullet
goes like through the front of his dad's
face she's like
he like slumps over it
just shoots the roof and the chandelier
falls down in the middle of the floor
the weight of the dad's finger like when
he hits the ground like just hits the
trigger on the shotgun and starts like
shooting behind him and just
looks like he kills his teenage daughter
just
like this is so brutal man only person
left is the [ __ ] camera man just like
oh no he's he's just riddled with me
he's actually the only one
he's like great i think we got it yeah
cool
that's like somebody can somebody take
this drops it just
hits the ground
you